ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO --
TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN DO YOU KNOW [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN.
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR WIENER.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
GRACIOUS GOD.
IN THIS WORLD OF SO MANY
MESSAGES WE OFTEN FEEL CONFUSED.
SOMETIMES WE BARELY HEAR YOUR
VOICE SUBMIT THE CLAMOR OF EACH
DAY'S DISCOURAGING NEWS.
AND WHAT CAN SEEM LIKE
UNRELENTING STRUGGLE RESTRAINT
TO FILL YOUR PIECE.
HELP US EACH DAY TO PAY
ATTENTION. TO NOTICE WHICH WORDS
PICTURES AND ATTITUDES ARE
FORMING US. TO USE OUR EARS TO
HEAR YOU.
OUR EYES TO SEE YOU.
AND OUR VOICES TO SPEAK YOUR
LOVE.
GRANT US THE COURAGE TO
CHALLENGE FALSEHOODS. TO
DISTINGUISH THE HONESTY FROM
HYPOCRISY. TO SAY GOODNESS WHERE
IT LIVES.
AND TO OVERCOME WORLDS WEARINESS
AND DESPAIR.
WITH THE OUR UNRELENTING
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMON GOOD.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
LEGIONS TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED.
OR AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THINKING TO MYSELF [inaudible]
ALWAYS LOVELY.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO SENATOR NIELSEN'S
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
BUT HE IS NOT HERE YET SO WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
THERE ARE NONE AT THIS TIME --
MOVED TO THE INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 333-313-32330
333-433-5330 SIX THREE THIRTY
SEVEN FIRST READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SENATE THIRD READING WE HAVE ONE
ITEM.
SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION.
SENATOR RUBIO [inaudible]
JUST.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT A MEMBERS I RISE TO
INTRODUCE A RESOLUTION THAT
WOULD PROCLAIM.
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINETEEN AS TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AND PREVENTION
MONTH THIS RESOLUTION WILL
ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
OBSERVE TEEN DATING VIOLENCE.
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MIND
WITH PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES TO
RAISE AWARENESS.
THAT WILL BRING UP AWARENESS
TOOK ABOUT TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE ALSO KNOWN
AS DATING ABUSE IS A SERIOUS AND
GROWING PROBLEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION A PREVENTION
PROGRAMS ENSURE A POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR YOUTH TALK
TO OUR TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE
INCLUSIVE.
WE MUST SUPPORT OUR YOUTH AND
EDUCATE THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE SO THAT
THEY CAN.
BEGIN TO HEAL.
AND AS LEGISLATORS WE MUST
ENSURE OUR YOUTH ARE NOT
IMMERSED IN A TOXIC RELATIONSHIP
THAT NORMALIZES VIOLENCE AND
INSTEAD THE YOUNG MAN EMBRACE
HEALTHY MASCULINITY AND THAT OUR
YOUNG LADIES ARE ALSO SELF AWARE
OF THEIR ATIONS.
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
BY -- TITLE
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY.
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING.
MORE LOCK.
BY MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY UMBERG.
LIKE US HE HI WINNER
[inaudible]
HI WILK HI HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS I
IT WAS MY PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE
FORMER MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONNIE LOWENTHAL BONNIE THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
MEMBERS WITH MOVE THAT ITEM ON
CALL WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE HAVE
ONE ITEM SENATOR ARCHULETA ARE
YOU PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
RELATIVE TO INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE IS A PROUD PRINCIPLE AND CO
AUTHOR TO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ACR. NINE TO
RECOGNIZE IS A STORE CO
SIGNIFICANCE OF INDIA INDIA
REPUBLIC DAY.
AT THE HERITAGE IN CONTRIBUTIONS
OF INDIAN AMERICANS TO THE STATE.
INDIA REPUBLICAN DAY REFERS TO
THE DAY INDIA'S CONSTITUTION WAS
ADOPTED IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY ON JANUARY TWENTY
SIX WHO GAVE THE CITIZENS OF
INDIA THE POWER TO CHOOSE THEIR
OWN GOVERNMENT AND PAVE THE WAY
FOR DEMOCRACY.
TODAY INDIA IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST DEMOCRACY BY POPULATION
AND SHARE THE COMMENT THE
COMMITMENT TO BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES OF FREEDOM
OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE WITH OUR
COUNTRY.
ACR NINE ALSO OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT.
ON THE MANY ACHIEVEMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE INDIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
MICE DISTRICT DISTRICT NUMBER
THIRTY TWO WHICH INCLUDES THE
CITY OF ARTESIA.
HOME TO THE LARGEST INDIAN IN
CLAVE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WERE MANY LIVE RUN BUSINESSES
AND HOLD CULTURAL EVENTS WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
BY BOAT.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
RESOLUTION I'M I THINK A GOOD
FRIEND FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
THE INDIAN COMMUNITY IS
CONTRIBUTED MUCH TO CALIFORNIA
AND US ON BEHALF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THIS
REPORT DAY THANK YOU.
pNIELSEN DID YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS MAY I PLEASE PROCEED.
NOT A PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO JOIN DAY.
OF RECOGNITION. FOR THE GREAT
NATION [inaudible]
OF INDIA.
A MAGNIFICENT HISTORY.
WONDERFUL TRADITIONS.
AND I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO
TRAVEL. TO THAT COUNTRY.
AND I'M MORE PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT WHAT I CALL THE PUNJAB
OF AMERICA.
WHICH IS JUST NORTH OF HERE.
THE YUBA CITY.
DO COUNTY AREA WHERE SO MANY
FROM THE PUNJAB SETTLE.
AND RAISE THEIR FAMILIES.
THAT IS A GREAT COUNTRY.
WONDERFUL TRADITIONS.
AND WE ALL OUGHT TO RECOGNIZE.
THE INDIAN AMERICANS TODAY AND
BY THE WAY THEY ARE ALSO KEEP.
PARTICIPANTS IN THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ASSOCIATION.
THAT MY WIFE AND I ARE FOUNDERS
OF YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING MANSER
ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU BEEN PRESENT MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THIS.
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
BYE BELL.
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI OR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
BY.
MORE LOCK I'M RAIL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
AYE AYE STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
BOB I COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY THIRTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
SENATE THIRD READING ITEM ONE
AND LIFT THE CALL ON THAT BILL.
MISTER SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
HI NELSON [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible] FIVE BY CITY
FOR NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE DO THAT DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANYTHING THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OKAY SINGING HEARING MEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ALL THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SIXTEEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL ROLL ON THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
HI -- TADA
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY UMBERG. FIVE I COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI BUT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL SKINNER.
I THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION EXCUSE ME THIS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CENTER NIELSEN ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY.
THE PRESIDENT PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE.
THE GREAT HONOR FOR ME TO DATE.
TO HAVE WITH US HERE TODAY IN
THE SENATE. ONE MY COLLEGE FACT
TEAMMATES.
PROBABLY THE GREATEST ATHLETE OR
ONE OF THE GREATEST IN HISTORY
FRESNO STATE.
AND WE'RE HERE AND I'M ASKING MY
COLLEAGUES. TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY.
IF HIS AND IVY'S DAUGHTER.
MICHELLE RENEE NICHOLAS.
THIS YOUNG WOMAN HAS QUITE A
LIFE STORY.
SHE WAS BORN WITH A GLARING
DEFECTIVE --
HEART. ONE THAT COULD RUIN THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE.
WHEN SHE WAS?
FIVE THEY FELT SHE WAS IN
CONDITION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT REPAIRED.
AND SHE MADE LED MANY DECADES
[inaudible]
THEREAFTER.
AND HAD A VERY PRODUCTIVE.
LIFE.
SHE WENT TO VALLEJO HIGH SCHOOL.
THEN THE CONTRA COSTA COLLEGE.
DAUGHTERS ARE DIFFICULT TO
PRACTICE PHLEBOTOMY.
AND ALSO MASSAGE THERAPY.
AND THEN LATER.
HER LIFE TOOK QUITE ANOTHER
COURSE.
SHE BECAME A VERY PROMINENT AND
RESPECTED WINE MERCHANT
[inaudible]
HE BEGIN THAT CAREER IN BUSINESS.
THAT'S ALWAYS DEDICATED HERSELF.
TO HER CHURCHES [inaudible]
HE ATTENDED LAST THE GREATER
FAITH CHURCH NOW CALLED
DESTINY'S CHURCH [inaudible]
AND VALLEJO.
WAS A PROMINENT MEMBER
[inaudible]
THEY'RE IN [inaudible]
SHE HAS. TWO BROTHERS A TWO
NEPHEWS DANNY JOHNSON AND TRAVIS
[inaudible]
JOHNSON.
IN WHETHER ALSO TODAY ARE SOME
OF THEY'RE JUST FRIENDS.
WHO HE WORKS WITH?
IN A TRANSPORTATION BUSINESS IN
THE LEGO.
SACRAMENTO.
THAN OTHER PLACES IN CALIFORNIA.
THEIR UNIQUE COMPANY.
THEY A ARE OWNED BY THEIR
EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
RENEE [inaudible]
MICHELLE RENEE.
THE BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
AND SHE TOOK WHAT FOR MANY WOULD
BE A DAUNTING.
AND IT'S LIFE CHANGER.
MADE A POSITIVE.
AN I BELIEVE KNOWING THIS FAMILY
AS WELL AS I DO THAT IS A
PRODUCT.
OF HER FACE.
THE HOPE THAT THAT FAITH GAVE.
FOR SHE MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
LIFE.
THE NOW THAT HEART.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THIS WHOLE.
NOW SHE IS WITH AND HAVEN'T
[inaudible]
WHETHER LORD.
THEY WITH JOURNAL AND MICHELLE
THE NAY NECKLACES HONOR TODAY.
AND THEN PRESENT I HAVE A VERY
BRIEF PRESENTATION TO THE FAMILY
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION. TO THE FAMILY
THIS IS A VERY SMALL
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
BUT IT REPRESENTS ASSESSMENT
SENTIMENTS OF ALL OF THESE GOOD
SENATORS.
WHO SERVE HERE?
WHO HONOR THEIR OWN [inaudible]
MANY TIMES.
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE YEAR.
THEY RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS TO OUR KNOWLEDGE GOOD
PEOPLE.
SHELVE RENE WAS A GOOD PERSON.
AND THIS IS A LITTLE MORE IN
THAT WE CAN PRESENT TO THE
FAMILY. TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WIFE
LIFE SO WELL LET.
THANK YOU N!N SENATOR NIELSEN.
BE SURE TO BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED
.
MEMBERS WE'RE UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE SERVI THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR FURTHER
ADJOURNING MEMORIES SENATOR
UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE GERMAN
MEMORY OF CHIEF TOM SCHOLZ WHO
PASSED AWAY JUST COUPLE WEEKS
AGO.
A CHIEFS SHOALS WAS ONE OF
ORANGE COUNTY'S FINEST PUBLIC
SERVANTS IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TOM SCHOLZ
BEGAN HIS CAREER WITH THE FULTON
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND EVENTUALLY
CLIMBED TO BECOME THE THIRTEENTH
FIRE CHIEF OF GARDEN GROVE.
WHILE SERVING IN FULTON --
IT CHIEF SHILTS UNDERTOOK THE
MOMENTOUS TASK OF CONSOLIDATING
THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN BOTH
FULTON AND GARDEN EXCUSE ME IN
BREA. TO CREATE A MORE ORGANIZED
AND SEAMLESS COMMAND STRUCTURE
IN THE AREA.
IN THE SPIRIT OF IMPROVING
EFFICIENCY OF THE LOCAL FIRE
AGENCIES TOM ALSO SPENT TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
TRAINING MENTORING AND SERVING
AS A ROLE MODEL TO HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF FUTURE FIREFIGHTERS.
WHO ATTENDED THE FIRE ACADEMY AT
SANTA ANA COLLEGE?
HE WAS THE TYPE OF PUBLIC
SERVANT THE SACRIFICE REPEATEDLY
TO MAKE THE DEPARTMENTS BETTER
AND SAFER FOR ALL OF US --
BEFORE BEING DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE FOUR PANCREATIC CANCER WAS
JUST SHORTLY BEFORE HE PASSED
AWAY.
TOM DEVOTED THIRTY YEARS OF HIS
LIFE TO KEEPING ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY SAFE FROM FIRE.
YEAH BE REMEMBERED BY ALL OF US
IN ORANGE COUNTY PARTICULARLY IN
GARDEN GROVE IT ESPECIALLY.
MOST DEARLY BY HIS WIFE KIM.
TWENTY NINE YEARS IS THREE
CHILDREN SERRA MULLIS'S AND
ANDREW --
TOM WAS A BLESSING TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND A BLESSING FOR ALL OF US
MAYES LIFE NEVER BE FORGOTTEN
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
AMERICAN PLEASE PASS ON OUR DEEP
CONDOLENCES [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
HEARING SENATOR NO OTHER JOURNEY
MEMORIES WE'D LIKE.
TO ON SORRY SERRA GLACIER.
THE BUT WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE TOWARDS COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE GONNA BE TO
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR GLACIER.
THEN THERE LEYVA CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I JUST AN ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT THE BUSINESS PROFESSION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
COMMITTEE WILL BE --
MEETING --
FIVE MINUTES AFTER WE ADJOURN
NOT ON THE FLOOR.
TODAY WE HAVE A SHORTAGE AND I'D
LIKE TO REQUEST THE MEMBERS
ATTEND PROP PLACE WE CAN DO OUR
BUSINESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR THEIR
LEYVA.
THANK YOU SIR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AS SOON AS B. M. P. ADJOURNED IN
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN EDUCATION
WILL MEET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
MEMBERS CENTER ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WE
WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT
NINE AM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS
THERE WILL BE TO COMMITTEE
MEETINGS FIVE MINUTES AFTER
FLOOR EASE RECESS THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL ALL
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS IS RECEIVED
WE RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM.
REMIT REMINDER BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS ROOM TWENTY FORTY
EDUCATION FROM TWENTY FORTY FIVE
MINUTES UPON RECESS THANK YOU
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS WILL BE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS FROM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE EDUCATION
IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
EDUCATION